[Music]
and can't please everyone news that's
submitted by a Chilean murca what did
you score Twitter is not happy with
Taylor Swift's newest music video
winners never gonna be happy true that's
true
they will never butter is a place of
fight but I love Twitter
you sure me too it's my favorite and I
hate I need to get up on it I think it's
more people on it are like their truest
self you know cuz on Instagram we're all
trying to like get monetized and like it
ads you know and like you know sure like
the queue perfect pictures but I feel
like on Twitter you could just go off on
like whatever you always just talking
about it I just don't follow the right
people then yeah you need to follow like
your your people I don't like that
energy though it makes me have anxiety
meets each other is sometimes too much
though sometimes I can go on it for me I
never really engaged with Twitter cuz I
always second-guess myself I'm like I am
do did I try to tweet for the hey [ __ ]
podcast and as I forgot I was logged in
because I was gonna tweet some stuff and
then I was like I'm not to tweet that
makes us sound cool we'll just let Gina
and buzz you're pretty good on Twitter -
oh you're funny
yeah York Times yeah anyway so Taylor
Swift she released a new song called you
need to calm down
you need to calm down it's like she
already felt all that hate comment
comments come her way so she was like me
to calm down when she's projecting yeah
pretty much yeah so they are saying that
the lyrics uh we're already overtly
anti-homophobia anti anti homophobia
that's good right yeah yeah how can you
be overtly anti-gay that's the problem
it cancels it out so it's like overly
they're saying she's over least like
them you gay it's like he loves you too
bro I know that was completely like
she's trying they're saying that she's
trying too hard
alright and I just am people so it's
yeah and it's just
they come off as genuine and is just
like yeah nothing this girl ever does
Jimmy ever felt genuine yes nobody likes
Taylor Swift yeah a lot of people like
so much so millions of millions of girls
like to us but I've always felt like the
[ __ ] that she does is like just for like
the cloud or with a little bit of you I
feel like you know when they had the
women's March or whatever um or just
different issues where she's such a
feminist and stuff and people were like
Demi Lovato was one of them when she was
just like come on like you're always so
active to calling yourself a feminist
you're not gonna speak up on this and
like her can't never said [ __ ] so I'm
just like maybe the real maybe it's just
what she's like monetizing it you know
what I mean like I said for this video
it's like there's a new song so I'm
gonna go with the gays cuz its Pride
Month so like you know um yeah I don't
not only cuz I think this year Pride
Month was like such a big deal so she's
just probably just trying to be on trend
yeah it's very trendy to be to be part
as I went to I went to pride with the
company I work with and yeah there was a
lot of people who weren't gay that were
there supporting days and it was awesome
but but it's also like yo you guys are
kind of late with but it's maybe if you
have never been to pray because I've
been like going to pride since I was
like 18 and I got they should tattoo
literally and so like a close and yeah
like straight people have been going to
pride but now companies are monetizing
off of it so it's like it's not a weird
thing but like now creators and like
super high or like big influencers are
saying like instead of buying from the
companies that are monetizing off of
this and saying like look we have
rainbows and everything's rainbow bye
and support the case of the gay resource
business owners businesses because your
money should be going to the gays
instead of the straights who claim to
yeah you know like support the gays
which Taylor chef is a straight course
she's an ally you know they're actually
circulating there people are speculating
that this whole thing that she's gonna
be coming on as bi so she's been she cuz
she's been hinting at it at different
points like before pointing it out the
fact that she's wearing the bicolor flag
in her hair like cuz that's just the
color I think it's like like a fuchsia
like a purple and like a
blue yeah and then because that's the
clever wig they're like well there was a
thing with that model that used to like
kind of live with her what's her name
kara Lee Kara she's dating that girl
from eyebrows you lion tattoo I hear I
hear I don't think it was that great go
avenge yeah she was right I don't know I
don't know I thought she's dating Ashley
Ben Farley I was thinking of this girl
named Carly something carly rae jepsen
no okay model this [ __ ] song call me
maybe go but yeah
so here's some screenshots from her but
she was donating right yeah so neat is
um yeah so people are upset about how
it's like it's just it's too much so we
covered that and then another one you
guys never satisfy people bro okay yeah
they're because they're cartoony and
like oh these are the bad guys these are
the good guys like it's very
over-the-top / - exactly so this part
really upset people a lot of white
people - but when you go to Pride dude
you sees a lot of gay white people no I
I mean I don't know if they're always
waiting like they make them look like
[ __ ] hillbillies like it's stupid
yeah quit building caricature with a but
there's a lot of executives like
billionaires that are ant like
chick-fil-a donating to anti-gay but
it's just that when you go to Prai you
literally see these kindness of people
like standing outside of the entrance of
the parade telling you like screaming at
you like you're all [ __ ] up like bus
about to going the festival and they're
like like gays not gonna feel this is
that that's what they have a problem
with it's like if you found any racist
stereotype if you had like an Asian
driver crashing into a wall like that's
[ __ ] up even if you were like what
that is what happens like you can't say
that like that's so stupid to go with
something so positive and uplifting
while stepping on other people
so this next tweet actually puts will
you both are saying together so it says
Taylor Swift's new song / video is
calming down and not throwing shade yet
the stereotypes and wrote that yet she's
stereotypes of protesters guests calming
down only applies if you agree with her
views yeah ashtag disappointed yeah so
yeah that's exactly what
they're like really did she really need
to did she really need the lazy classes
stereotype last time I checked there
were plenty of pretty polished people
spewing and tolerance tubes yeah and
there's plenty people that bad that are
very accepting yeah it's like true I saw
one thing about this on Twitter where it
was like there's a lot of those queer
eye guys guys in that show they often
are fixing up guys that are you know
kind of like yeah it's like they were
like honey I'm in like but then they're
like super accepting of the guys on the
show right and they're really sweet so
it's like I guess she could have done
the whole video without putting those
guys there and it would have just been
focusing on like the positivity of the
gay community
yeah sure people would have been more
accepting of it cuz you could have had
that whole video and like like it's a
happy video and when you see all those
gay like people you're like oh sure like
I know LA and I know the queer eye guys
and like it makes you happy yeah yeah
but then having to put like those other
people it's like did you have to do that
yeah exactly that's true the nose it was
like he she's speaking to an audience
that's really stupid it's like your
consumers aren't that stupid like we get
that you know these people are getting
backlash or they're not being treated a
certain way but you don't have to put
other people I think it's just weird I
don't feel like there's too many people
bopping around and Taylor Swift music
that are like and I hate gays oh says
not to okay yeah that's gonna really
dude really changing I don't know are we
gonna say what if she actually wanted
that controversy yeah yeah yeah like to
just there you type it that way so that
then she would get more yeah I don't
like her team at least maybe she's not
this like crazy mastermind yeah I think
so because I think the hook of it was
putting in Katy Perry in it I think that
was the the part that I was supposed to
be talking abut then she lost him what
the pretentious like oh what the [ __ ]
they're supposed to be talking about
Katy Perry that we're friends now yeah
no but when you they saw Katy Perry in
her it was like a french french fries
and a hamburger and then it ended in
like a heart yeah so what if that's like
foreshadowing her coming out as bisexual
yeah that's what we were saying but but
people didn't get that yeah they were
sluggish on the over here like why did
you need all this you
and then also people were bothered on
how it was mainly men representing Oh
Ellen yeah I was just Ellen that other
chick Oh from oranges and you black
what did it mean to the tribal woman ah
[ __ ] no this girl oh yeah but Laverne
Cox - she's a woman yeah yeah nothing
like it was just a very few it was
mostly guys yeah
are there oh nevermind I'm not sure no
there is nevermind
well good that was just like are there a
lot of openly gay women like in the
limelight and I'm like yeah there is
various but they're just like right up
her alley and what I mean by that
they're like just as attractive as her
or like you know what I mean like she
would they don't want to hurt them to
oversee yeah I like Rui
what is her Ruby Rose Ruby Rose like I
Madden her they're like you'd be like
all right let's all focus on baby then
maybe she did hit all these people up
and they were like I can't get job yeah
we don't know but yeah a lot of people
were just like managed a part of me does
feel kind of bad nah [ __ ] yeah a part
of me does feel kind of bad because you
can never do anything right right like
she's never because of the caliber that
she is she's trying to make a stance on
something and she's just not gonna win
it
she's just over the top yeah it's too
true then she could be kind of like
Beyonce who doesn't really have much of
a stance though who can really oh like
Beyonce though but she's so neutral
nobody bill she's that neutral like she
did the whole Super Bowl performance in
the Black Panther tribute attire oh she
did yeah and I also feel and she got a
lot of backlash for that and but she
like she was a college dude like like I
never like we don't want to see a
political [ __ ] during happy cuz she was
dirty on the Colin Kaepernick thing with
the kneeling thing so there was like
already very divided
and super bowl supposed to bring her
together alright alright beyond says
team is just always on point like she
does these messages so subtle yeah
bagger like oh [ __ ] cuz like when she
was doing that like I didn't even feel
the political side cuz I was like all II
just looked dope you're just like in oh
yeah yeah and like even like unheard
2016 tour like she would start her
concert and would just say like
feminists in the back like you would be
like oh don't but then she never sang
about anything else about feminists
somebody run the women hit you over the
head with it like the who run the world
girls all the women and the pivot and
you're like me alright I think your back
yeah I think it back there is a tasteful
way to do it she just her and her team
[ __ ] up yeah them so just really look
over like it was just very again like it
was yeah it was a hammering you on the
head like I think what's happening a lot
of people are saying that Taylor's
copying other people like Beyonce I
think Taylor's coming out it kind of
seems like faker like she's trying to be
this but then like Beyonce if it feels
more natural yeah like you can people I
think people can feel when like you're
just putting it on yeah and that's why I
probably the gay community is even
annoyed by her
yeah isn't like this is not natural yeah
I feel like the gay community really
vibe would like Lady gaga
you know like that was like their queen
that was like oh [ __ ] young lady guys
like are [ __ ] you know she doesn't like
outright do [ __ ] yeah they thought she
was gonna get political at the Superbowl
when she did hers and she didn't yeah
like she was very like neutral I like
yeah so I mean maybe now Taylor Swift is
like alright well I'm losing the young
little ones cuz they're growing up and
like who am I like leeching onto now cuz
like leeching on yeah I feel like
Beyonce like it's like our generation
like she's also a lot with the black
women you know what I mean so like
that's like our queen you know Taylor
she was just kind of floating around
trying to like this oh boy just like the
gays and the guys I like that way
yeah yeah so her petition so she did
include this at the end of her video cuz
I'm sure that out yeah so it pretty much
says for people to go sign the petition
for the Equality Act and now it has
three hundred and sixty thousand it is
they're trying to get to the language
they're trying to get to 500
I felt like she would have more pull she
gets like twenty five million views on
her YouTube I think you have to be 18 to
probably sign a petition three thousand
eighty year old sons about it yeah her
video currently has 41 million views all
my god and only three hundred thousand
people who wanted to say a lot of them
are the same people that are like angry
that hate watching it I mean it's still
use yeah it reminds me it's similar to
like the Gillette commercial thing when
people were outraged because it was just
so over the top like we already like I
feel like did you like commercial was
like maybe like the right getting super
upset like why are you showing this on
our face this time the gays like we are
like you know it stop like you don't
need to like represent for any of us
that much like [ __ ] we're good over
here you know like to stand over there
with them and like everyone's chilling
you know yeah so maybe that's the
difference that make sense yeah but I do
have to point out that not ever not
everyone felt that way and there were a
lot of people in the gay community that
were pretty sure and saying like thank
you thanks for you know being are our
personal yeah any exposure is still good
positive exposure yeah exactly it is
yeah he's normalizing all of that